during pregnancy there are lots of
unknowns and many decisions to be made
about your health
and the health of your unborn baby and
now deciding on the coveted vaccine has
been added to the list
bianca holman is live at a local
fertility clinic
sharing more about covid and pregnancy
good morning bianca
hey good morning sheri so we're here at
the fertility center of las vegas we're
in one of their recovery rooms
and we understand that if a pregnant
woman does get covered there can be tons
of
complications that can really impact her
health and to share more
um i'm joined here by dr kerry obedient
thank you so much for
waking up with us so the vaccine and
pregnancy you know
why should pregnant women and even those
who have yet to have children
decide to go ahead and get the vaccine
pregnancy while someone has
coveted is much more dangerous than if
that same person gets coveted while
they're not pregnant
they're more likely to be affected by
complications like
admitted to the icu on a ventilator
being deceased
all of those things are more compete
more common
in pregnant women who have covid and so
we recommend that for any woman who is
considering getting pregnant
she get protected with a vaccine in
order to prevent
the complications of covet affecting not
only her but her baby as well
yeah and i understand we're here in the
recovery room and i wonder have you all
seen an increase
in families coming and trying to think
about their their family planning
what has it been like women have gotten
much more attuned to what their
priorities are and
really not just women and couples men
everybody
and so we have seen quite a few more
couples come
come see us in order to start their
families yeah more time at home you
start thinking about your future and
again what that family looks like now
how can people learn more information
because again there's probably a wealth
of questions
when it comes to fertility when it comes
to covet how can folks learn more
when it comes to that and about again
planning family planning
so our website has a wealth of
information fertilitycenterlv.com
i have a podcast with two of my
colleagues called fertility docs
uncensored and
both of those places address a lot of
the information about
not only getting pregnant but pregnancy
in innoco
kind of world and how to go about
approaching it
yeah well again you have even off camera
i've asked her tons of questions
uh before you know somebody who wants to
be a mom in the future you kind of
wonder about these things you know
you're in a text group with your
girlfriends you're meeting from up for
brunch
and you start talking about babies and
family so you provided a wealth of
information and again you heard about
her podcast and the website
to get more information about your
fertility your pregnancy
cover 19 and of course the vaccine gonna
send it back to you guys in the studio